This is 99% Indusible. I'm Roman Mars. Ian Chilogue is a radio producer. You might recognize his name from the end credits of the NPR quiz show, Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me, or as the co-host of the Now Defunct Podcast, How to Do Everything, which I just loved. It's such a good show.
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。伊恩·奇洛克是一位广播制作人。你可能在NPR问答节目《等等，等等，别告诉我》的片尾字幕中见过他的名字，或者知道他是现已停播的播客《如何做任何事》的联合主持人，我非常喜欢那个节目。那真是一个很棒的节目。
He has a new podcast out right now, launching this week, and it's delightfully weird. Well, the show is called Everything is Alive, and it's delightfully weird. Well, the show is called Everything is Alive and it's an interview show in which all the subjects are inanimate objects. So, I talked to things. So what made you want to do a show like this?
他现在有一个新播客，本周刚刚上线，而且它怪得令人愉悦。嗯，这个节目叫《万物皆有灵》，它怪得令人愉悦。嗯，这个节目叫《万物皆有灵》，这是一个访谈节目，所有的受访对象都是无生命物体。所以我采访了各种东西。那么，是什么让你想做这样一个节目呢？
Well, a couple things. One, I think it's just like, I would just sort of think this way. Like, you know, I'd it's just like, I would just sort of think this way, like I'd, you know, I'd get up from a chair and think about what a terrible job the chair had and like, and like how the chair must feel about being sad on all the time. And then also like, I think producing for so long, you're always trying to get to like the primary source, you know? So long, you're always trying to get to the primary source.
嗯，有几点原因。第一，我觉得这就像是……我本来就会这样思考。就像，你知道，我会从椅子上站起来，然后思考这把椅子做的工作有多糟糕，以及它一直被人坐着会有什么感觉。还有，我觉得做了这么久的制作人，你总是试图找到一手来源，你知道吗？做了这么久，你总是试图找到一手来源。
And you're always looking for experts. I thought it would be really fun if you're putting together a piece about rainbows or whatever. And rather than talk to the physicist who understands rainbows, if you could actually talk to the rainbow. So that's kind of the idea. I know that listeners to 99% of us will are fully capable of accepting that even the most mundane objects are infused with great meaning and can say something about us as humans, but you may not be prepared for that object to actually talk. So I ask Ian for a primer on how to
而且你总是在寻找专家。我想如果你正在制作一篇关于彩虹之类的文章，与其去采访了解彩虹的物理学家，不如直接采访彩虹本身，那会非常有趣。这就是大概的想法。我知道《99%无形》的听众完全能够接受即使是最平凡的物体也蕴含着巨大的意义，并且能向我们揭示作为人类的某些道理，但你可能还没准备好让那个物体真的开口说话。所以我向伊恩请教了如何
listen to everything is alive. You know, if I was talking to a candle, say, like a bedroom candle, like it's not every candle, it's not speaking for every candle. It is one candle that is set on one nightstand forever and like been blown out by one person forever and has a relationship with that person, but they're kind of aware of their object communities, like it knows more about candles than we do. It also has very distinct lifetime of experiences. But the things that it says are all factual. I think I was surprised by that when I first heard the episodes that I've, the samples that I've heard.
收听《万物皆有灵》。你知道，如果我是在和一支蜡烛对话，比如卧室里的一支蜡烛，它并不是代表所有的蜡烛，它不为所有蜡烛代言。它就是放在床头柜上、一直被同一个人吹灭、并与那个人有着某种联系的一支蜡烛，但它们对自己的物体群体是有所了解的，比如它比我们更了解蜡烛。它也有非常独特的一生经历。但它所说的一切都是事实。当我第一次听到我听过的那些样本片段时，我对此感到很惊讶。
Yeah. They know things. They know real things about their world. For the most part, they're the inanimate object version of the person at the party who like always has an anecdote for everything. They're very aware of history and of stories of what they are. So even though the situation is quite absurd on the face, when you hear a fact, it's a true fact. Yeah, there is so much about the kind of personal life of the object that you know, you know,
是的。它们知道事情。它们了解关于它们世界的真实情况。在大多数情况下，它们就是无生命物体版的派对达人，总是对每件事都有轶事可讲。它们非常了解历史以及关于它们自身的故事。所以，尽管表面上情况非常荒谬，但当你听到一个事实时，那是一个真实的事实。是的，关于物体个人生活的部分，你知道，你知道，
you know, isn't exactly real. But when I'm telling a story about something real, I don't cite it. You know, I don't tell you where I heard it. And so we're just letting the objects behave in the same way. And so there's probably, you know, there's gonna be some mystery.
你知道，并不完全是真实的。但当我讲述关于真实事物的故事时，我不会引用出处。你知道，我不会告诉你我是从哪里听来的。所以我们只是让物体以同样的方式表现。所以可能，你知道，会有一些神秘感。
And hopefully people will Google and figure out if things are real or not. This is everything is alive, hosted by Ian Toulog. Well, let's just start, Settelain, have you introduced yourself for us? My name is Lewis and I am a can of go-to cola. That's a store brand. Go-to, K-O-2. Cola.
希望人们会去谷歌搜索，弄清楚事情是真是假。这是《万物皆有灵》，主持人是伊恩·奇洛克。好吧，让我们开始吧，塞特莱恩，你能为我们做个自我介绍吗？我叫刘易斯，我是一罐“Go-to”可乐。那是超市自有品牌。Go-to，K-O-2。可乐。
So it's similar to Coca-Cola. Similar. People call it a knockoff. I've been called the best of the worst. You know, if you wanted to get my honest opinion, I believe in a blind taste test. Your average person wouldn't be able to tell the difference between me and a can of regular Coca-Cola,
所以它和可口可乐很像。很像。人们称它为仿冒品。我被称为“最差中的最好”。你知道，如果你想听我的真心话，我相信盲测。普通人是无法分辨出我和一罐普通可口可乐的区别的，
but yeah, bottom shelf. We can describe it comfortably as bottom shelf. I'm at peace with that. Literally on the- Most of the time, yeah. Okay. Well, there's a lot I want to talk to you about today. Do you need any water or anything? No, no, no. I'm completely self-contained. I want to ask you about your time before you ended up in the fridge. Yeah. You're in now. So you, um, you, I take it where you were in a supermarket? Yep. And where were you?
但确实，属于底层货架。我们可以很自然地把它描述为底层货架。我对此很坦然。字面上就在——大多数时候是这样。好吧。嗯，今天有很多我想和你聊的话题。你需要喝水或者什么吗？不，不，不。我完全是自给自足的。我想问问你在进入冰箱之前的那段时光。是的。你现在在里面。所以我假设，你在一家超市里？是的。你在哪里？
I was in a safe way. I was bought at a case. So there were 24 of us. We were all purchased together and actually, uh, our next residence was a bowling alley for a 12 yearold birthday party. I saw most of the rest of my case drunk at that party. I was not drunk. I was saved for later and brought home and put into a refrigerator and then forgotten about for a few months placed in the back of the fridge. Sure.
我在西夫韦超市。我是成箱买的。所以我们有24个。我们是一起被买走的，实际上，我们的下一个住所是一个12岁生日派对的保龄球馆。我在那个派对上看到我那箱里的其他罐子大多被喝光了。我没被喝掉。我被留到最后，带回家放进冰箱，然后被遗忘了几个月，放在冰箱的最里面。当然。
I froze in the fridge. I was in the very back and the temperature got very cold. I didn't freeze all the way through, but I had a frozen couple of weeks. You were slushy inside? I was slushy inside. I had a brief adventure when they realized I was still in the fridge and they took me out for a road trip. I got to sit in the front seat cup holder, you know. And I took a little fun road trip down to Florida and then back again and they never got around to drinking me on that trip and they put me back on the fridge and that's where I've been ever since. It sounds like you were almost chosen so many times. What does it feel like when you're, say, at this birthday party and you're waiting for your moment?
我在冰箱里冻住了。我在最里面，温度变得非常冷。我没有完全冻透，但我经历了冰冻的几周。你里面变成冰沙了吗？我里面变成了冰沙。当他们意识到我还在冰箱里时，我经历了一次短暂的冒险，他们带我出去公路旅行。我坐在前排的杯架里，你知道。我进行了一次有趣的公路旅行，去了佛罗里达又回来，他们在旅途中一直没喝我，又把我放回了冰箱，从那以后我就一直待在那里。听起来你好像好几次差点被选中。当你比如在生日派对上等待你的时刻时，那是什么感觉？
We've ever seen the movie, Jaws. Yeah. So you know the story that Robert Shaw tells to Roy Scheider and the other guy. Anyway, you know the story about the USS Indianapolis where he's in the water and the sharks are coming and he's waiting to be picked off and he's waiting and having that long dark night and one by one is seeing his friends go. That's kind of what it was like for me. It was terrifying. And on the one hand I was very angry at human beings for being in this position to consume us. And then on the other hand I was also very angry how come you didn't want to consume us. And then on the other hand, I was also very angry how come you didn't want to consume me?
你看过电影《大白鲨》吗？看过。所以你知道罗伯特·肖对罗伊·谢德和另一个人讲的故事。总之，你知道关于印第安纳波利斯号巡洋舰的故事，他在水里，鲨鱼来了，他等着被吃掉，他在等待，度过那个漫长黑暗的夜晚，一个接一个地看着他的朋友们离去。我当时的感觉就是那样。太可怕了。一方面，我非常愤怒人类竟然处于这种消费我们的位置。另一方面，我也非常愤怒，为什么你们不想消费我们呢？然后另一方面，我也非常愤怒，为什么你们不想消费我呢？
Yeah. When you think about being consumed by a human, do you think about the human that you want to be in? If and when I'm finally consumed, I hope I'm consumed by someone who enjoys it. But I like to imagine that if you're drunk immediately, that instead of being a painful process, there's the sort of first moment of relief the can is cracked open. All of this internal fizzing that I have going on finally has somewhere to go. that I have going on finally has somewhere to go. Just sort of drown down from your external can and you have that last moment where you're fulfilling your purpose and beginning to blend in with this human being
是的。当你想到被人类消费时，你会想到你想要进入的那个人类吗？如果我最终被消费了，我希望是被一个享受它的人消费。但我喜欢想象，如果你被立即喝掉，那与其说是一个痛苦的过程，不如说是在罐子被打开的那一刻有一种解脱感。我体内所有的嘶嘶声终于有了去处。从你的外部罐子里流出来，你有最后那一刻，你实现了你的目标，并开始与这个人融合，
and you become part of their story. Truthfully, here's how I expect to go, assuming that I am consumed. I'm expecting it's going to happen in the middle of the night, where I'm not waiting for it and someone's going to open the fridge and pull me out, and that'll be that. It would be nice to be poured into a nice big pint glass, you know. Frosty mug would be a pretty good way to go. Happy pleasant, you know. I doubt that's going to happen though. They don't reserve Frosty Mugs for go to coales. That's just another one of those facts of life. How did you see Joss? Oh, the human being who lives in my house was watching Joss. They took me out of the fridge and kept me on the table.
你成为了他们故事的一部分。老实说，这就是我预期的结局，假设我被消费的话。我预计这会发生在半夜，我没在等它，有人会打开冰箱把我拿出来，事情就是这样。如果能被倒进一个漂亮的大品脱杯里就太好了，你知道。冰镇马克杯会是一个很棒的结局。快乐、愉悦，你知道。不过我怀疑那不会发生。他们不会为“Go-to”可乐预留冰镇马克杯。那只是生活的又一个事实。你是怎么看《大白鲨》的？哦，住在我家的人类在看《大白鲨》。他们把我从冰箱里拿出来放在桌子上。
I thought this is it. This is my big moment. Kind of part of me. There was the Robert Jossine where he's telling the story of the Indianapolis. And I was thinking, boy, this is just too perfect. This would be amazing. It was reaching for me. He was going to go for me,
我想就是现在了。这是我的高光时刻。我的一部分。那是罗伯特·肖讲述印第安纳波利斯号故事的场景。我在想，天哪，这太完美了。这会很棒。他伸手去拿我。他要选我了，
and then at the last minute, another human being came into the house and scolded him on not drinking soft drinks, so I put me back on the fridge. Wow. Yeah, I would have been perfect, huh? Yeah. You know, I should ask you,
然后在最后一刻，另一个人进了屋，责备他不该喝软饮料，所以把我放回了冰箱。哇。是的，那本来会很完美，对吧？是的。你知道，我应该问你，
there's a lot of talk right now about the health effects of soft drinks. People tend to think of them as very unhealthy. So, Naring, do you feel unhealthy? Do I feel unhealthy? It's hard to say it because I think if you were feeling the way I feel, you would feel unhealthy. Right. But I feel like me. I can't say that that means I feel, you would feel unhealthy. Right. But I feel like me.
现在有很多关于软饮料对健康影响的讨论。人们倾向于认为它们非常不健康。所以，纳林，你觉得不健康吗？我感觉不健康吗？这很难说，因为我觉得如果你感觉像我这样，你就会觉得不健康。对。但我感觉像我自己。我不能说这意味着我感觉，你会觉得不健康。对。但我感觉像我自己。
I can't say that that means I feel good. But to go back to your question, unhealthy drinks are not like a new thing by any means. Have you ever heard of Rady Thor? Rady Thor? Rady Thor? All right, so back in the 20s, there was an energy drink with Radyum called Rady Thor, okay?
我不能说这意味着我感觉很好。但回到你的问题，不健康的饮料绝不是什么新鲜事。你听说过“镭水”（Radithor）吗？镭水？镭水？好吧，回到20年代，有一种含镭的能量饮料叫“镭水”，好吗？
And the idea was it was just radioactive material in water. They claimed radithor gave you energy and cured a bunch of things. They also implied that radithor increased male virility. Radithor also killed, you know, people. So people would just drink radioactive material dissolved in water. Mm-hmm. I'm just looking it up here. There's actually, there's an eBay ad. There's a bottle of radiotheraic for sale. Oh, come on now.
它的理念就是水里含有放射性物质。他们声称镭水能给你能量并治愈很多疾病。他们还暗示镭水能增加男性活力。镭水也杀死了，你知道，人。所以人们就会喝溶解在水里的放射性物质。嗯。我正在查这个。实际上，有一个eBay广告。有一瓶镭水在售。哦，得了吧。
Currently, $659. You gotta be kidding me. It says here, this certified radioactive water was advertised as a, quote, cure for the living dead and, quote, perpetual sunshine. It goes on. One guy who used it, Evan Biers, died from radiation poisoning and they had to bury him in a lead-lined coffin. Yeah, and that's what you get when you drink radioactive material.
目前是659美元。你在开玩笑吧。上面写着，这种经过认证的放射性水被宣传为，引用，“活死人的解药”和“永恒的阳光”。还没完。一个使用它的人，埃文·拜尔斯，死于辐射中毒，他们不得不把他埋在铅衬的棺材里。是的，这就是你喝放射性物质的下场。
So they made a beverage, which not only killed a man, but his dead body would have had they not taken precautions killed all life around him. Yes, presumably his dead body is still radiating the poisons that he drank from radii thor. In fact, the the ad goes on. They exhumed him for study in 1965 and his remains were still quite radioactive. Yep. It then mentions that the developer of Radithor was not an actual medical doctor. Yeah, that sounds about right to me too. Also, the bottle is in very good condition.
所以他们制造了一种饮料，不仅杀了一个人，如果他们不采取预防措施，他的尸体还会杀死周围所有的生命。是的，据推测他的尸体至今仍在辐射他从镭水中喝下的毒素。事实上，广告继续写道。他们在1965年为了研究挖掘了他的遗体，他的遗骸仍然具有很强的放射性。是的。它还提到镭水的开发者并不是真正的医学博士。是的，这听起来很符合我的预期。而且，瓶子保存得非常好。
So there's your original power drink for you. That says to me more about human beings than it does about soft drinks, to be perfectly honest. Our willingness, our eagerness to find something to... Your chronic search for potency. Yeah, that's my evaluation of humanity. Chronic search for potency. Hello. Hey, I'm calling for Jeff.
所以这就是你的原始能量饮料。老实说，这对我来说，比起软饮料，更能说明人类的问题。我们的意愿，我们寻找某种东西的渴望……你对效力的慢性追求。是的，这就是我对人类的评价。对效力的慢性追求。你好。嘿，我找杰夫。
Yep. Hey, Jeff, you're the man behind the bygone times vintage, right? Haha, yeah. I'm guilty. I notice one of your eBay listings. So you put up the Rady Thor? Rady Thor? Yeah.
是的。嘿，杰夫，你是“往昔时光复古店”背后的人，对吧？哈哈，是的。我认罪。我注意到了你的一个eBay列表。所以你上架了镭水？镭水？是的。
Yeah. Is that for real? Oh, yeah, what happened was I was at a flea market and I found a set of about 20 25 of these things Okay, it was like a shipping crate or something and So yeah, I have sold a few of those. Now, and is it a reproduction or is it an original bottle? No, these are original. Yeah, original. Did you check them with a Geiger counter?
是的。那是真的吗？哦，是的，事情是这样的，我在跳蚤市场发现了一套大约20到25个这样的东西。好吧，就像一个运输箱之类的。所以，是的，我已经卖掉了一些。现在，它是复制品还是原装瓶？不，这些是原装的。是的，原装的。你用盖革计数器检查过它们吗？
I have not. I don't know. I just assumed they wouldn't have any. There's no content in them obviously. But I haven't, no, I didn't, I didn't check up on the guy who got your count. I don't, I suspected that since I was from the 1920s, it would be done gone. I think maybe it wouldn't be gone. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. Maybe they wouldn't, I don't know, maybe they would, I don't know. Can I put them under a black light or something? I hope it's still active, I would.
我没有。我不知道。我只是假设它们不会有任何东西。显然里面没有内容物。但我没有，不，我没有，我没有去查那个盖革计数器。我怀疑既然是1920年代的，它应该早就没了。我想也许它不会消失。是的。是的。我不知道。也许它们不会，我不知道，也许它们会，我不知道。我能把它们放在黑光灯下或者什么吗？我希望它仍然有活性，我会的。
Huh. That raises the interesting questions, sir. Did you know much about Radithor when you you know when you know no yeah no I got on the fortunately now we have the internet so google was quite helpful it's a really an interesting story i don't know if you've taken the time to uh... to look into it but it's nice meeting yeah well i just i just heard about it it's uh... crazy that we we human i know i like the story about the guy who uh... I just heard about it. It's crazy that we humans don't. I know. I like the story about the guy who died from it, and then they dug him up in the 60s and has led
嗯。这提出了有趣的问题，先生。你对镭水了解很多吗，当你，你知道，当你，你知道，不，是的，不，我幸运的是现在有了互联网，所以谷歌非常有帮助。这是一个非常有趣的故事，我不知道你是否花时间去研究过它，但很高兴见到你，是的，好吧，我只是，我刚听说它，这太疯狂了，我们人类，我知道，我喜欢那个关于那个家伙的故事，他，我刚听说它。这太疯狂了，我们人类不。我知道。我喜欢那个死于此的人的故事，然后他们在60年代把他挖出来，他有铅
blind coffin. He was still radioactive. That's why I feel like you should maybe get checked out. You are here. I think I will. Yeah. I think I will now that you said that, because I didn't really think that the glass
衬的棺材。他仍然具有放射性。这就是为什么我觉得你应该去检查一下。你就在这儿。我想我会的。是的。我想我现在会了，既然你这么说了，因为我真的没想过玻璃
would hold any of that, but I guess it's possible. You know, radiation you don't want to mess around with, I guess, when it comes down to the wall. No, I hear you. Hey, I have to, I'm driving and I don't want to, I'm getting onto a video of road now so I need to unfortunately hang up on you. Got it, yeah, be safe. Okay, bye. Lewis, one quick thing I want to ask you about, I have in my life occasionally dropped a can of soda. No, yeah.
会保留任何那种东西，但我猜是有可能的。你知道，辐射是你不想乱搞的，我想，当涉及到……不，我听到了。嘿，我必须，我在开车，我不想，我现在要上一条视频路了，所以我不得不遗憾地挂断你的电话。明白了，是的，注意安全。好的，再见。刘易斯，我想问你一件事，我这辈子偶尔会掉落一罐苏打水。不，是的。
Has that ever happened to you? Oh, it's an awful experience. You feel, I mean, obviously very shaken. There's a rush, I guess, of a human being in terms would be like a rush of adrenaline. And for a while, you're feeling just very, very hyper after the shakeup. And then you start to sort of resettle back to a neutral state, but you have this awful kind of nauseous, sick-y, sleepy feeling after the fact. And you feel kind of dumb, you know, the shakeup kind of like
这发生在你身上过吗？哦，那是一次糟糕的经历。你感觉，我的意思是，显然非常震动。我想人类会有一种肾上腺素激增的感觉。有一段时间，你在震动之后会感到非常非常亢奋。然后你开始慢慢恢复到中性状态，但事后你会有一种糟糕的恶心、生病、昏昏欲睡的感觉。而且你感觉有点笨，你知道，震动有点像
rattles you a little bit, and it takes a little bit of time for your intelligence to kind of come back to you It's an awful experience. Hey, I imagine too, like we often, after that happens, we will tap on what would be your head. Don't, it doesn't do anything. It doesn't. Don't. There's no reason to do it. It doesn't do anything to the carbonation. All it does is annoy us in a very sensitive moment. Yeah, don't do that. You're listening to everything is alive on 99% of this book. So, Lewis, this might be awkward to talk about, but I feel like there's a hierarchy
把你摇晃了一下，需要一点时间让你的智力恢复过来。那是一次糟糕的经历。嘿，我也想象，就像我们经常在那种事发生后，会敲击你的头部。别，那没用。它没用。别。没有理由这样做。它对碳酸化没有任何作用。它只会让我们在一个非常敏感的时刻感到烦恼。是的，别那样做。你正在收听《万物皆有灵》，《99%无形》节目。所以，刘易斯，谈论这个可能会很尴尬，但我觉得苏打水之间存在等级制度，
to sodas, at least in terms of how humans think about them. At the top, there's, you know, Coke and Pepsi, and then there's seven up and Sprite, and then there's these, you know, like your sunkissed and great soda, Fanta, that are kind of at the bottom. I wonder if that, does that hierarchy, does it mean the same thing to you? Well, let me tell you something about Fanta. I mean, sure, here in the U.S.,
至少在人类如何看待它们方面是这样。在顶端，你知道，有可乐和百事，然后是七喜和雪碧，然后是这些，你知道，比如你的新奇士和葡萄汽水，芬达，它们处于底部。我想知道，那个等级制度，对你来说意味着同样的事情吗？好吧，让我告诉你一些关于芬达的事。我的意思是，当然，在美国，
it's not the most sophisticated soft drink, but overseas, it's huge, like Japan, huge. Fanta. Fanta. In Thailand, it's all over the U.S., it's not the most sophisticated soft drink, but overseas, it's huge, like Japan, huge. Fanta. Fanta. In Thailand, it's all over the place. If you walk down the street there, you'll see half open bottles of Fanta everywhere. Stradberry Fanta in particular, everywhere, just hanging out.
它不是最精致的软饮料，但在海外，它非常受欢迎，比如日本，非常受欢迎。芬达。芬达。在泰国，它到处都是，在美国，它不是最精致的软饮料，但在海外，它非常受欢迎，比如日本，非常受欢迎。芬达。芬达。在泰国，它到处都是。如果你走在那里的街上，你会到处看到半开的芬达瓶子。特别是草莓芬达，到处都是，就在那儿放着。
Just like sitting on the street. Yeah, just on the street. Because humans there use Stradberry Fanta as an offering to ghosts. So they leave it out on the street because they're giving it to ghosts. Yes, friendly ghosts according to local costume, love, sweet red soda. So if you leave it out, it attracts them
就像坐在街上一样。是的，就在街上。因为那里的人类把草莓芬达当作给鬼魂的祭品。所以他们把它放在街上，因为他们把它给鬼魂。是的，根据当地习俗，友好的鬼魂喜欢甜甜的红色汽水。所以如果你把它放在外面，它会吸引它们，
and they hang out around your house and protect you from, you know, I guess whatever one friendly ghost might come around. Who I guess don't love sweet red soda. Right. Do you know what it is about strawberry fanta in particular? Because of the color. So there's a theory that it's because they can't do
它们会在你家周围徘徊，保护你免受，你知道，我想任何一个友好的鬼魂可能会来。我想它们不喜欢甜甜的红色汽水。对。你知道关于草莓芬达特别之处是什么吗？因为颜色。所以有一个理论是，因为它们不能再做
blood offerings anymore. And so strawberry fanta, which is another, you know, red viscous liquid, would be the next best thing. Strawberry fanta among the sodas available to us looks the most like blood. Yeah, which I personally don't see. Okay, but you know, it's a Thailand thing. We humans, we think a lot about, you know, spirits or at least, you know,
血祭了。所以草莓芬达，这是另一种，你知道，红色的粘稠液体，会是次好的选择。草莓芬达在我们能买到的苏打水中看起来最像血。是的，我个人看不出来。好吧，但你知道，这是泰国的事情。我们人类，我们想很多关于，你知道，灵魂，或者至少，你知道，
what might happen to us after we die? Do you as a cola? Do you think about that the afterlife? Yeah. Oh, yeah. How do you not think about it all the time? Yeah. Oh yeah. How do you not think about it all the time? Yeah. Because I'm reaching that age myself, or I'm probably not going to be around that much longer.
我们死后会发生什么？你作为一罐可乐？你考虑过死后的世界吗？是的。哦，是的。你怎么可能不一直想它呢？是的。哦，是的。你怎么可能不一直想它呢？是的。因为我自己也到了那个年纪，或者我可能不会再存在太久了。
You are, I mean, you are recyclable. Yeah. Which opens up a whole other conversation. You know, my body, my can will almost certainly be repurposed. And then that leads me to, you know, ask questions of like, well, have I already been repurposed? I don't know. You could have been any number of sodas or anything else.
你，我的意思是，你是可回收的。是的。这开启了另一个对话。你知道，我的身体，我的罐子几乎肯定会被重新利用。然后这导致我，你知道，问一些问题，比如，好吧，我已经重新利用过了吗？我不知道。你可能是任何数量的苏打水或其他任何东西。
An airplane? I could have been. I actually, when I was younger, I used to have a recurring nightmare that I was, there was a plane crashing. There was an ocean and a beach. And then it was nighttime and it was raining and there was a plane crashing on the beach. And I used to like to think that in a previous existence I was part of an airplane. And this was some sort of memory that had traveled with me. Maybe I was part of like a ventilation
一架飞机？我可能是。实际上，当我年轻的时候，我经常做一个反复出现的噩梦，我是一架飞机坠毁了。有一个海洋和一个海滩。然后是晚上，正在下雨，有一架飞机在海滩上坠毁。我过去喜欢认为在以前的存在中，我是飞机的一部分。这是一种随我而来的记忆。也许我是波音747上的通风系统的一部分之类的。你把你的罐子称为你的身体，或者把你的身体称为你的罐子。人类谈论身体和灵魂之间是否存在等同关系？对不起？不，不。我叹气只是因为我希望我有这个问题的答案。是否存在等同关系？是的。是的，笛卡尔时代以来人类一直在处理的身心问题，对我们这些苏打水罐来说太熟悉了。我只是一个罐子吗？我是苏打水吗？成为苏打水意味着什么？我是那里更大的苏打水海洋的一部分吗？我只是个体化的苏打水吗？我是与罐子相互作用的苏打水吗？我是被里面的苏打水慢慢侵蚀的罐子吗？我想过很多次。是的。我没有答案，但这确实是我一直在纠结的事情。我本质上是什么？
system on board of a 747 or something. You refer to your your can as your body or your body as your can. Is there an equivalency between you know a human's talk about body and soul? Is that I'm sorry? No, no. I'm only sighing because I wish I had the answer to this question. Is there an equivalence? Yes. Yes, the body-mind problem that human beings have been dealing with since the days of day-cart is something all too familiar to us, cans of soda. Am I just a can? Am I soda? What does it mean to be soda? Am I part of the larger ocean of soda out there? Am I just the individuated soda? Am I soda interacting with a can? Am I can being slowly eaten away by the soda inside me? I thought about this a lot. Yeah. I don't have an answer, but it's something I wrestle with all the time. What am I fundamentally?
就像波音747上的系统一样。你把你的罐子称为你的身体，或者把你的身体称为你的罐子。人类关于身体和灵魂的讨论之间是否存在某种等同性？抱歉，你是说？不，不。我叹气只是因为我希望我有这个问题的答案。有等同性吗？有的。是的，人类自笛卡尔时代以来一直在处理的身心问题，对我们这些汽水罐来说也太熟悉了。我只是一个罐子吗？我是汽水吗？成为汽水意味着什么？我是外面那片更大的汽水海洋的一部分吗？我只是个体化的汽水吗？我是与罐子相互作用的汽水吗？我是被里面的汽水慢慢侵蚀的罐子吗？我思考过很多次。是的。我没有答案，但这确实是我一直纠结的问题。从根本上讲，我到底是什么？
Once the soda is gone, the can remains, but by by me. I think, yeah, who knows? Who knows? These are the mysteries that permeate every level of existence as far as I know. I have to say, I think about the type of can you are with the pull tab. Mm-hmm. And then I think about other cans in the kitchen, you know, like a soup can.
一旦苏打水没了，罐子还在，但……我不知道。我想，是的，谁知道呢？谁知道呢？据我所知，这些是渗透在存在各个层面的谜团。我必须说，我想到你这种带拉环的罐子。嗯。然后我想到厨房里的其他罐子，你知道，比如汤罐。
I don't know if you know any soup can. I know a couple of soup cans. And it occurs to me me you are So lucky Because you think about the way a soup can gets open. Oh, yeah, that the I can't open or to me Seems like a torture device. It is and let me tell you something else too The I thank God every day of my life that I was not born to can't administer any soup I at least have lived a life. I know where I've been, you know? I'm not all of my dreams may have necessarily come true.
我不知道你认不认识汤罐。我认识几个汤罐。我想到你真是太幸运了，因为你想到汤罐被打开的方式。哦，是的，那个开罐器对我来说似乎是一种酷刑工具。它是，而且让我告诉你另一件事，我每天都感谢上帝，我没有出生在汤罐里。我至少过了一辈子。我知道我去过哪里，你知道吗？我所有的梦想未必都实现了。
I may have taken a couple of bad turns here and there, but at least at the end of the day I've been witness to my own life. These poor bastards are stuck in these soup cans. I talk about hermetically sealed. They lose all sense of time and perspective. When you open a can of soup, when they wake up, they have no idea how much time has passed. They're like astronauts coming out of cryogenic freeze. And they're all spaced out and they're completely disoriented.
我可能在这里或那里走了一些弯路，但至少在一天结束时，我见证了我自己的一生。这些可怜的混蛋被困在这些汤罐里。我谈论的是密封。他们失去了所有的时间感和视角。当你打开一罐汤时，当他们醒来时，他们不知道过了多少时间。他们就像从低温冷冻中出来的宇航员。他们都神志不清，完全迷失了方向。
They don't know what's going on. And their wake up call is being torn open by these damn can openers. What a nightmare of an existence. Their flesh is literally busted open, only to wake up into a world that they don't know anything about. All the rest of us stay away from the cans of soup. And I'll be honest with you, I feel awful about it. But whenever I try to talk to a can of soup,
他们不知道发生了什么。他们的叫醒服务是被这些该死的开罐器撕开。多么噩梦般的存在。他们的肉体被字面意义上地撕开了，只是为了醒来进入一个他们一无所知的世界。我们其他人离汤罐远点。老实说，我对此感觉很糟糕。但每当我试图和汤罐交谈时，
they are weird. You've mentioned that you're feeling like you're nearing the end of your life. Oh, yeah. What do you feel old or do you? Oh, yeah. Oh, very much so. I know for a fact, I'm old.
它们都很奇怪。你提到你感觉你快到生命的尽头了。哦，是的。你感觉老了吗？或者你？哦，是的。哦，非常老。我确实知道，我很老。
I can look at my expiration date. Okay. And can I ask how close you are? T-minus two weeks to go, my friend. Wow. So what? But you could keep going on after that. I could, it's not recommended, but I could. Does it seem, I mean, I think about this with you,
我可以看我的保质期。好的。我可以问你还有多久吗？距离截止日期还有两周，我的朋友。哇。所以什么？但你可以在那之后继续存在。我可以，虽然不推荐，但我可以。这看起来，我的意思是，我想到你，
because I'm sorry if I have this, isn't the right way to put it, but it seems like your purpose is to be consumed by a human. Yeah. And so, you know, we all want to serve our purpose. We all want to be useful. Yeah. And yet, for you, the moment of your use is the moment where you are no more.
因为我很抱歉如果我有这个，这不是正确的表达方式，但看起来你的目的是被人类消费。是的。所以，你知道，我们都想实现我们的目的。我们都想有用。是的。然而，对你来说，你被使用的那一刻就是你不再存在的那一刻。
And I wonder if that's something you anticipate with optimism or if it feels like, you know, approaching the end? That's a paradox, isn't it? It is, yeah. Well, I guess on the one hand, I do sort of You know approaching the end. It's a paradox isn't it? It is yeah. I guess on the one hand I Do sort of Dread the idea of being consumed. Yeah, you know all beings endeavor to persist in their own being
我想知道你是否带着乐观的态度期待这一点，或者它感觉像是，你知道，接近终点？那是一个悖论，不是吗？是的，确实。好吧，我想一方面，我确实有点……你知道接近终点。那是一个悖论，不是吗？是的，确实。我想一方面，我确实有点害怕被消费的想法。是的，你知道所有存在都努力坚持自己的存在。
Spinoza said that I heard about that from a couple coffee But on the other hand I Guess on some level I still about that from a couple of coffee. But on the other hand, I guess on some level I still hope that I will kind of fulfill myself by being consumed. I think that dream is still very much alive. Though if I'm being perfectly honest with you, I do sometimes fear that that moment is past. You know, I do, I do sometimes fear that that moment is passed. I feel weird saying this, but I could drink you.
斯宾诺莎说过，我从几杯咖啡那里听说的。但另一方面，我想……从几杯咖啡那里听说。但另一方面，我想在某种程度上，我仍然希望我能通过被消费来完成我自己。我认为那个梦想仍然非常活跃。虽然如果我完全诚实的话，我有时确实担心那个时刻已经过去了。你知道，我有时确实担心那个时刻已经过去了。我觉得说这个很奇怪，但我可以喝你。
Right now? Yeah. I mean, I want, I, I, I, I want you, I'm, I am thirsty, but I also, I want this to be a good moment for you. I want you to be red. I don't want you to do it if you're not ready. Well, I'll make a deal with you. I've always said I wanted to go with my eyes wide open. I'm prepared to end it here if you promise me that even if you're disgusted by how I taste, you will finish the camp. I will make you that promise. Is there anything you want to say to the humans you've encountered, the cans you've encountered, the countertops you've known? I think overall I would say life is a gift and a blessing
现在吗？是的。我的意思是，我想要，我，我，我，我想要你，我，我口渴，但我也，我希望这对你来说是一个美好的时刻。我希望你是红色的。如果你还没准备好，我不想让你这样做。好吧，我和你做个交易。我一直说我想睁大眼睛离开。如果你答应我，即使你对我的味道感到恶心，你也会喝完这罐，我就准备在这里结束它。我会给你那个承诺。你有什么想对你遇到的人类、你遇到的罐子、你认识的台面说的吗？我想总的来说，我会说生命是一份礼物和祝福，
and I don't believe anything ends, but everything simply transforms into the next thing. I would say if I can be a little bit soft-hearted and sentimental for a moment or two, it's a gift to get to be anything at all. Well, maybe what we'll do in the just in the interest of journalism is I'll drink about half and then we'll check in again. Great. Do you want to talk while I'm drinking you? I don't. No. Okay. No, I want to have the full experience. Okay, but I'll check in with you at the halfway mark. Alright, so I'm picking you up. Give me one second.
我不相信任何事情会结束，一切只是转化为下一件事。如果我可以稍微感性一下，能成为任何东西都是一种礼物。好吧，也许我们为了新闻报道的利益，我会喝掉一半，然后我们再检查一下。太棒了。你想在我喝你的时候说话吗？我不想。不。好的。不，我想有完整的体验。好的，但我会在一半的时候和你确认。好吧，我要拿起你了。给我一秒钟。
Okay. Are you ready? Mm-hmm. This I have to say feels delightful. All right, well, I guess cheers to you with you. Here's hoping for the best. I mean you're you are delicious. Thank you. You're very gentle. This is a trippy feeling. I'm not going to lie. All right, my first report. Feeling very spacious inside right now. I feel like I've got room to be. Yeah. But I'm also I'm feeling the warmth of the tummy. A very strange thing. I mean two places at once spacious in my own body, but feeling warm and secure in your own tummy. Wow
好的。你准备好了吗？嗯。我必须说这感觉很愉快。好吧，好吧，我想为你干杯。希望一切顺利。我的意思是，你，你很美味。谢谢。你很温柔。这是一种迷幻的感觉。我不撒谎。好吧，我的第一份报告。现在感觉里面非常宽敞。我觉得我有空间存在。是的。但我也是，我感觉到了肚子的温暖。一件非常奇怪的事情。我的意思是同时在两个地方，在我自己的身体里很宽敞，但在你自己的肚子里感觉温暖和安全。哇。
All of a sudden I find myself Thinking about my body. I'm thinking about my body and I'm hoping that my body is a good place for you I think so. I don't mind telling you my first impression of the inside of your own tummy. You seem to be taking pretty good care of yourself. Thank you. Yeah. I am seeing some, are you sweating? Sings some, with joy.
突然间我发现自己在思考我的身体。我在思考我的身体，我希望我的身体对你来说是一个好地方。我想是的。我不介意告诉你我对你肚子内部的第一印象。你似乎把自己照顾得很好。谢谢。是的。我看到一些，你在出汗吗？看到一些，带着喜悦。
All right, I'm going to, I'm going to have a little more. I am seeing some are you sweating seeing some with joy? All right, I'm gonna I'm gonna have a little more you go ahead and finish me off. Okay Are you are you still there? Everything is Alive is produced by Jennifer Mills and Ian Chilock. This episode had reporting from Patrick Wynn and Timothy Dorgonson. In the piece we heard the song Sheets 2 by the band Mountains of their album Coral. Lewis, the can of generic cola, was played by Lewis Cornfeld. Find out more at everythingisalive.com. I'll have a behind the scenes discussion with Ian and a preview of this season of Everything
好吧，我要，我要再喝一点。我看到一些，你在出汗吗？看到一些，带着喜悦。好吧，我要，我要再喝一点，你继续把我喝完。好的，你，你还在吗？《万物皆有灵》由詹妮弗·米尔斯和伊恩·奇洛克制作。本集有帕特里克·温和蒂莫西·多根森的报道。在片段中，我们听到了Mountains乐队专辑《Coral》中的歌曲《Sheets 2》。刘易斯，那罐普通可乐，由刘易斯·科恩菲尔德扮演。在everythingisalive.com了解更多。我将在之后与伊恩进行幕后讨论，并预览这一季的《万物皆有灵》。是什么吸引你讲述刘易斯，那罐普通可乐的故事，作为《万物皆有灵》的第一集？我想我设想了一罐普通可乐可能会有点自卑。它总是被拿来和大家伙比较，你知道，可口可乐。它甚至被制造出来试图欺骗人们以为它是可口可乐，但你知道，它有自己的身份。也许这让它变得苦涩。我是指情感上的，而不是味道上的。
Is Alive after this. What attracted you to tell the story of Lewis, the generic cola, as the first episode of Everything Is Alive? I think I imagined that a can of generic cola would maybe have a chip on a shoulder. It's always being compared to like the big guy, you know, the Coca-Cola. It's even been made to try and trick people into thinking it's Coca-Cola, but you know, it has its own identity. Maybe that makes it bitter. I mean that in the emotional sense, not in the flavor sense.
但因为普通事物和非普通事物之间存在关系，它本身就会有一些有意义的个性。而且对话就像真正的采访。就像，我们不写剧本。我们只是让一个人做一点研究，或者我们给他们研究。然后我采访他们，我不知道。所以就像，你知道，事物本身已经有一点性格了，我觉得更有趣，演员也更容易配音。我知道刘易斯是演员。那个eBay的人是演员吗？不。那是真人。是的，那是真人。是的，我们给他打了电话，我不知道，他的Facebook页面上有一个号码。
But because there's a relationship between generic things and non-generic things, that it would already have some personality that made sense. And the conversations are like the real interviews. Like, we don't script them. We just ask a person to do a little research or like we give them research. And then I interview them and I don't know. And so like things where, you know, where there's a little bit of character already to the thing, I think it's more fun and it's easier for the actor to voice it. I know Lewis is an actor. Is the eBay guy an actor? No. That's a real person. Yeah, that's a real person. Yeah, we called him up, I don't know, there was a number on his Facebook page.
是的，他是真的。他很好。我告诉你。很好。因为他是一个非常好的角色。是的。太神奇了。而且他很好，虽然。是的，他很好。
Yeah, he's real. He's okay. I'll tell you that. Good. Because he's a very good character. Yeah. That's amazing. And he's fine, though. Yeah, he's fine.
我确实，我开始做一点研究，关于玻璃是否真的能保持辐射，我实际上不知道答案，但他，我可以为他的情况担保，他很好。你能告诉人们在这一季的《万物皆有灵》中可以期待什么吗？我们有，我的意思是，我们正在谈论的很多东西，我们正在和一个叫梅芙的灯柱谈话。有一个叫塔拉的肥皂。现在，我正在做一个关于杰克的采访，他是一个邮箱，一个捕鼠器，实际上，她必须使用化名，但她
I did, I started to do a little research about like if glass would actually hold radiation and I actually don't know the answer to that, but he, I can hit for his case, he's fine. Can you tell people what to expect in this season of everything is a lot? We have, I mean, a number of things we're talking to, we're talking to a lamppost named Maeve. There's a bar of soap named Tara. Right now, I'm working on an interview with Jake, who is a mailbox, a mouse trap, who actually, she has to use a pseudonym But she
她正在，捕鼠器正在对她被要求做的事情有很多反思。她不，是的，她不想杀老鼠。她对她能做的事情有很多其他的想法，考虑到她被赋予的形式，没有一个是像捕鼠器一样好的。捕鼠器只能捕鼠，事实证明。没错。它们真的都会非常不同，我们真的希望它们都是不同的东西。它们将是深思熟虑的物体，它们将是不同的东西。它们将是深思熟虑的物体，它们将是肤浅的物体。
She's having the Maltstrafe is having a lot of second thoughts about what she's asked to do. She doesn't yeah, she does not want to kill mice She has a lot of other ideas about what she could do instead, given the form she was given, known of which R is good as being a mouse trap. Mouse trap can kind of only mouse trap turns out. That's right. They're all really going to be different and we really want them all to be different things. They're going to be deep thinking objects and they're going to be different things. They're going to be deep thinking objects, and they're going to be superficial objects.
而且我认为它们将是不讨人喜欢的物体。你知道吗？当然有一些物体不太喜欢我。嗯哼。哈哈哈哈哈哈。是的，我的意思是，我认为我们的目标只是让它成为一个多样化的事物社区，你知道，所以。对。它们是不喜欢你，原则上还是通过你采访它们的行为？不，是的，是通过我采访它们。
And I think they're going to be unlikable objects. You know? There are certainly objects who don't like me very much. Uh-huh. Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha- Yeah, I mean, I think our goal is just that it be a diverse community of things, you know, so. Right. Do they not like you on principle or through the action of you interviewing them? It's no, yeah, it's through me interviewing them.
这很有趣，你知道，就像我意识到，因为我真的，我采访一个事物的感觉和我采访一个人的感觉一样。我真的这么觉得。有时，在采访之后，我会意识到有些事情我不敢问。我怎么了？为什么我害怕冒犯那堆灰尘？但我确实害怕了。对你来说，有没有一个终极目标，你正在努力实现？有，是的，是的。
It's fun, you know, like I realize, because I really, I feel the same interviewing a thing as I do interviewing a person. I really do. And sometimes, after the interview, I'll realize there was something I was afraid to ask. And what was wrong with me? Why was I afraid of offending that dust pile? But I was. Is there an ultimate get for you that you're like working your way up towards? There is, yeah, yeah.
你知道，我试图非常认真地对待这些事物。但我确实认为，如果这个节目的最后一集是对冰块的采访，由Ice Cube（冰块）扮演。这是一个，我，我会非常满足。《万物皆有灵》。这是来自PRX的Radiotopia的最新节目。在everythingisalive.com，radiotopia.fm，Apple Podcasts和Radio Public上获取它。
You know, I'm trying to take the things very seriously. But I do think if the final episode of this show was an interview with an ice cube played by ice cube. It's a- I- It'll be very satisfied. Everything is alive. It's the latest show from radio toopia from PRX. Get it at everything isalive.com at radiotopia.fm on Apple Podcasts and Radio Public.
《99%无形》是旧金山KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@节目99PI Orc，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但我们在网上的真正家园是99PI.org。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
99% Invisible is a project of KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the web is 99PI.org. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99% Invisible是旧金山KALW的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上找到我们。但我们在网络上真正的家是99PI.org。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。